the pandemic is changing the way we
travel and the way we work too as
millions of americans wait to return to
the office many are seizing the chance
to work remotely from anywhere and a lot
are staying longer in the rentals airbnb
says nearly half of the half of the
night's book from last july to september
were for stays of seven days or longer
ceo that's brian chesky announced this
yesterday guess what he's going to do
he's going to be traveling and staying
in airbnbs over the next few weeks he
joins us first on cbs mornings from his
airbnb in atlanta hey brian chesky i'm
so glad to see you brian
good to see you gail i'm so happy to be
here from atlanta
yeah so i'm curious listen all of us
have stayed in airbnbs why did i know
you've stayed in airbnbs too yourself
but what is the point you're making why
are you doing this now
well gail i think that the pandemic has
very likely caused one of the biggest
changes to travel says the advent of
commercial flying and that is because
for the first time millions of people
not everyone but millions of people
don't have to go to the office five days
a week and because many of these people
don't go office five days a week they're
not tethered to the city they where they
live in and so they can now potentially
live anywhere and so some people are
choosing long weekends some people are
choosing to go away for the entire
summers if they have families but others
like me i can actually live kind of
nomadically and so every couple weeks
i'm going to be traveling to different
cities across the country and you know
even around the world because we're
seeing millions of people on airbnb
interested in doing this and i want to
really test the experience optimize and
show that you can actually run a really
big company doing this and it means a
lot of people can do this so so brian
you're telling me that you went on the
airbnb website clicked around through
all those pictures
and then picked the place that you're in
right now
i did and i i you know what i'm looking
for is i don't really want to feel like
i'm traveling
i want to feel like i actually live
somewhere even if i'm there just for a
couple weeks and so i'm looking for a
place in a local community i'm here in
reynoldstown in atlanta this is
incredibly nice home by his really
wonderful host named kimberly and i
really love great design good wi-fi so i
can do interviews things like that
wi-fi is key that's for sure right i
want to talk about a new policy that you
guys are rolling out in oregon um to
fight racial bias i know that there was
a lawsuit settled um tell us about that
policy
well i think just a step back you know
airbnb is all about connecting people
all over the world on new year's eve
four and a half million people were
staying in airbnb so if we're going to
bring people together the opposite of
bringing people together is
discrimination we don't stand for it we
make every member on airbnb sign a
community commitment now one of the
things we did is we worked with the
state of oregon to limit how much
information a guest shows about them so
we don't show their full name or their
photo just their initials we think this
could reduce discrimination of hosts
deciding they don't want to host
somebody because of the color of their
skin or or their name now the key thing
is we're constantly innovating and
testing different ways to reduce
discrimination we have an entire team
dedicated to this and so i think that
for airbnb to work we cannot have
discrimination because that's an
existential threat to the company
how is omicron change the game for you
brian because i got my favorite daughter
kirby just had a little baby and she's
looking for child care and one of the
things that she told me last night is
they're going to look for airbnb to
quarantine someone before they bring
them into the house because omicron is
so off the charts i actually thought
that's a really great idea how has that
changed the game or has omicron changed
the game for you
yeah i mean basically the longer the
pandemic goes on and every new strain
keeps the pandemic going on longer the
more people don't travel the way they
used to they used to go to a city for a
couple days typically for business
travel often staying in a hotel district
and the longer it goes on gail you're
totally right people are now looking to
stay longer almost half our business is
longer than a week a fifth of our
business by nights are people staying
longer than a month we have people
staying for entire seasons they're
obviously quarantining they're getting
away so it's really changing the game
the longer this pandemic goes on the
more the world never goes back to the
way it was and that means travel isn't
going back to the way it was it means
that traveling and living are starting
to blur and people are truly living in
homes all over the world
and what happens if you find something
brian that's not cool in an airbnb
property what you gonna do
what i'm gonna do is get right on the
phone of my team and say we need to
figure out the root causes so no one
else experiences this and i'm already uh
creating a list of ideas based on this
experience and i think that like one of
the big risks of a ceo is you're stuck
in your ivory tower and i feel like you
got to get on the field and be
constantly using your product
well brian that's great brian don't
forget to leave a review it's part of
being part of a community uh we
appreciate you being great to see you
brian being part of our thank you good
to see you very much